hello the meeting of college of
commissioners in nothing to end and I
will give you the minutes of it
in a moment but let
me first give some news
concerning president jonckheere
because many of
you have asked yourselves how he is I  can
tell you that yesterday's surgery
went well and they are scheduled to be
released already today from
intensive care and he will now continue his
recovery and before you
ask me his return to the office
will depend on  the speed of his
recovery
we negotiated a hearty Macedonian next
week
this system must be m and to finish these
announcements welcome two
groups of visitors
we have with us today
Polish journalists expert in
European issues as well as a group
of  young German colleagues who
work for the regional press
welcome welcome vita walk me from
quesnoy to the same latitude and quickly
yes thank you it's  st a question 1 2
questions